I think there's something to be said
though for working on the concept of God
the theorist
Hortense Spillers says that our concepts
do violence in the world right our
concepts like do work of establishing
some people as more important than other
people some species is more important
than other people and I really worrying
about the concept of God I really worry
about it I worry about the work that it
does I worry about the way that it still
seems to establish humans as superior to
every other species I worry about the
way that it still seems to establish men
as more important than women and like
gendered others I worry about the way
that because of Europe's traditional
alignment with that particular
monotheistic God it tends to establish
the supremacy of Europe and by extension
America over every other region of the
world so I worry that if we don't do
work on that concept of God we just
leave it there
intact as grounding all of these
hierarchies and then we can say oh but
it doesn't exist right that God doesn't
exist but that doesn't get rid of all of
those conceptual adherence --is that
keep those dualities and those
hierarchies in place I think there's
something to be said for like working on
the concept itself to say you know what
divinity does not mean omnipotence
doesn't mean you can just go in and do
whatever you want it means a kind of
relational negotiating power because
this is the way that we see that nature
works right nature doesn't just so
destroy everything and then recreate
stuff a new nature works with what it
has with all sorts of bacteria and ants
and mushrooms and trees all kind of
doing their part to make a forest a
forest that I think is a more productive
way of thinking about divinity than a
dude in the sky and again I think if we
leave it to particularly conservative
monotheists to define what God means and
the rest of us just sort of sneak off
into atheism then you've got God right
they've got our most power
concept and I'd rather I'd rather do
work on that concept and is it possible
than to have form of like theism that
isn't that sort of dude in the sky in a
way that it's like someone that is
higher than humans and it's controlling
controlling us does pantheism sort of
how can you radically break that away
yeah from like an idea of divinity yeah
so the so the idea of pantheism would be
something like and I say would be
because it's not clear to me that we've
got a decent pantheism at the moment and
so I'm trying to figure out how to kind
of stitch it together and what it might
look like but the idea pantheism would
be that what we mean by god is the
natural world itself right and by
natural I mean also the cultural world
technologies right every the world
around us the material world around us
there's also a world of ideas that stuff
is got how can we get away with calling
it God because what we mean by God is
the source of all things the life in all
things the end of all things why not
just say like that's that's what we mean
by the universe it's what gives us life
it's what's right sustains us it's what
swallows us back in and makes us into
something else by recombining our atoms
right so pantheism would mean something
like what we mean by God is the universe
itself so then we want to ask well like
how does the universe work and how does
how does how does the world work and we
can think about it on a small scale
about the earth or like a patch of
forest right how does the natural world
work to get stuff done and really the
agents of doing stuff in the universe
are not human beings
it's like bacteria right bacteria are
amazing creators well what I mean if we
like thought for a little while about
the creative work that bacteria like a
bacterial theology write about these
like microscopic agents as the the
engines of life as the engines of
newness as the engines of what would it
mean to think about rather than you know
consciousness or rationality as being
some divine principle which is usually
what we you know this characteristic we
ascribe to God
what about like gravity or magnetism
it's amazingly powerful forces that hold
things together that drive things apart
they get things like start
somewhere else start from some different
place in the universe that does creative
work and build your model of divinity
there and I almost think you could start
from kind of anywhere like a mustard
seed or an acorn or it right I think
that kind of pantheism would encourage
us to look all over the place and see
how and where we see like newness
creativity productivity at work and has
pantheism how to history what is the
history of pumpkin it's a really
hilarious history pantheism doesn't have
a great history it was coined as a term
at the outset of the 18th century it was
coined it's just like a nasty word a
like a bad thing to call dopey
philosopher the dopey philosopher in
question was a man named Burke Spinoza
who died toward the end middle end of
the 17th century and he had this idea
that he was he used the term God or
nature Deus si vain at Torah God or
nature and he sets forth this idea he
gets excommunicated from his Jewish
community and Amsterdam and for hundreds
of years afterwards in order to gain a
university professor ship in Germany for
example you had to take a pledge against
Spinoza he had to promise that you did
not affirm this so the position known as
pantheism again was was just like a
nasty name like a bad thing to call a
terrible person it's got a bit of a
resurgence in sort of 18th and 19th
century German idealism but most of
those German guys who take it up end up
then making fun of it when they get
older and kind of ridiculing it and
converting to a more orthodox form of
Christianity there's so again there's
not a great history of pantheism I think
you can see it kind of subtly at work in
say some of the German poets some the
English poets even some the American
transcendentalists but folks don't tend
to sort of take up the cause of like a
banner of
deism so again part of the work that I'm
trying to do now is to kind of stitch it
together to like find some friends to
cobble it together William James who's
an American philosopher pragmatist and
psychologist in the beginning of the
20th century begins to say you know what
it looks like pantheism is the only
viable option for us these days like we
can't believe in this humanoid
father-god anymore we're probably gonna
have to be pantheists he's like but I'm
not really quite sure what this means so
he starts getting getting thinking about
it but he doesn't quite set it forth so
that's what this work is trying to do
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you